well speaking of independent film and
sort of the grittiness and ugliness that
goes along with it with this film for
day out of days do you think the topic
of invisibility in Hollywood is a little
too is like that elephant in the room
people don't want to talk about it maybe
is that too scary whereas I would love
to see it a lot of independent film
people I think would love to but maybe
the mainstream yeah who cares let them
get mad that means nothing's going on
you know it's just if you touch somebody
and you make them angry it's almost like
a very opposite but close to making them
very happy so if you've done that then
you spark something inside somebody a
debate inside somebody and as it as a
filmmaker
that's all you kind of hope to do you
know it's touched somebody in a way so
go for it
yeah well you said you like stories
about pain and not in the way that you
like to see people transcend through
that I'm not talking about like 24 the
movies how do you know write and
transcend and maybe they're not they
don't go to that you know perfection but
that they're at an okay place what is it
about that that's so fascinating to you
and why do you think we all like to see
it I think we're all as humans I think
there's two things or maybe it's just me
but it's very sometimes shocking to
realize that your pain and your
insecurities and fears are very very
very connected to other people in the
world who also feel that their pain and
insecurity is very singular so when you
can reach out I always say when I'm
writing and it's really hardcore I call
it the cringe moment like and it's about
you know I can use the worst part of me
in it and I'm like no it's gonna be the
part that everybody's gonna like because
everybody's gonna be able to relate to
something that is unsaid but needs to be
articulated you know so I think finding
a journey with somebody is very
important to your own journey and how
you can live through other people but
how you can learn something about you
know yourself and not maybe not be as
ashamed about it or maybe find something
really interesting about it that you
wouldn't necessarily feel if you were
just by yourself you know and isolated
you